By the way, no matter what he says, you can only respond with "Thank you."
Okay.
No matter what she says, you are only allowed to respond with "Thank you."
Shakira Keller is a fantastic writer.
Thank you.
You are smart.
Tamara is beyond beautiful.
Thank you.
Because of who you are,...
...you have inspired me to be a better and stronger person on this planet.
Thank you.
Okay, Corina. Now, Oscar is going to repeat all of those one by one...
...and for each one, I want you to explain how what he says makes you feel...
...and how it's significant to your relationship, okay?
Okay.
Shakira Keller is a fantastic writer.
I love that.
One of the things that I do really pride myself on is my writing,...
...and as much as I don't let you read what I write,...
...I really do appreciate the fact that you think that.
It makes me really happy.
You are the most beautiful person I've ever met.
I think that's very sweet.
I don't think that's true, but I feel very humbled that someone thinks that.
Accepting compliments doesn't mean you're arrogant or conceited,...
...it's healthy for both you and your relationship...
...by validating your partner's thoughts.